I opened the letter and it was something
along the lines of how dare you
bringing a child into this world at your
age it can hit you in a place that that
um where you're the most vulnerable I
feel like that's like the kind of
Cruelty yeah Hoda codby opens up about
getting Mom shamed for having kids at an
older age I guess when you know what's
real and you know what it is
hers right well the today anchor shares
a moment about getting negative comments
that actually hurt her feelings and it
involves becoming a mom in her early 50s
I got a letter that was addressed to me
in somebody's handwriting to my house I
opened the letter and it was something
along the lines of how dare you
bringing a child into this world at your
age
don't you know what you're doing to that
child like it went on and on and I was I
was like I took my breath away because
that actually was my ouch yeah I was
scared yeah like is this something that
um that is smart for me to do Hoda
shares two children with her ex Joel
schiffman the former couple adopted
daughter Haley in 2017 after Hoda's 2007
battle with breast cancer left her
unable to concede that little girl Haley
Joy yes
she's fine
um is a daughter she is the love of my
life for me I always had this thing
inside me that just like it was a voice
I couldn't quiet
it was a voice that wanted to be a mom
but thought it was too late it was that
voice and I think you know you can push
a voice like that away for a long time
but sooner or later it comes back up
and you have to address it fast forward
two years Hoda dropped another surprise
on her today co-anchors when she and
Joel adopted a second daughter hope
it's a girl
we like the idea of Haley have a sibling
because she has such interesting
circumstances to grow up in any way so
it would be nice to be able to share it
with somebody
so how does Hoda deal with hate when it
comes to being a mom well she's turning
to her own upbringing to look at the
positive when I was feeling terrible
because I did I was
my dad passed when I was in college and
I remember thinking we have our parents
for a period of time I know the
foundation he left I know it was worth
every second of that time so I thought
about that too I sort of thought I'd
missed my window and I think a lot of
women might feel this way it's sort of
like you get busy with work and you
you're in a marriage that maybe doesn't
work then I had an illness and then I
looked at my life and said like what
happened like I missed it and then I
started to do that thing that I think
women do and we all do it's like you
know what I don't get everything and I'm
happy I'm going to keep what I have and
say I'm say thank you God for this and
you can only I think push feelings down
so long before you just can't and one
day you say you know what I'm gonna try
like why not me and I think you know for
any of us your timing's right because
it's for you
[Music]